fight against multiple sclerosis
ms is one of the few diseases that
cannot be cured by replacing the
affected tissue with implant technology
but the experts at biodyne have created
nanites that
when injected into the spinal cord
provides long-term
undirected repair to the neural tissue
the cost of this cutting-edge therapy
treatment has been listed
at 700 000 euro dollars per month
for the second consecutive week the
landfill inferno in the remnants of
atlantic city continues to rage on
the 10 000 acre dumping ground ranks
among the world's largest
and contains both toxic and biological
johnny see what happened something feels
off here
you don't say don't mean the wreck
i mean the run city's most courteous
chauffeur
ups and drives away from the scene of an
accident
crying
[Music]
[Music]
you would
[Music]
hey
you don't know me but you will name's
dino
deal with downtown city center me
yeah i know what about you hot stuff
need anything you call me remember
dino knows everybody
trash
huh
oh
sometimes
sorry would you be so kind as to give me
your lawyer's contact information
[ __ ] you cirque brain
thank you processing data now please
wait
uh hey dale hello sir or madam
how can i be of service what's got into
you
don't recognize me you sent me a message
saying i should come in about the
accident
you are currently speaking to a dellame
network subroutine
alas my operational capabilities are
limited
could you please clearly recite your
incident report give them any numbers
your identity has been established
mr hans jonas what phrase would best
describe your experience of incident
number seven
seven one one one one
zero one zero nine six
actually a little heartbroken about my
damaged ride but i'd rather talk to the
real delamin if i can
v my apologies if the receptionist was a
bother
i'm preoccupied with the crisis that is
ongoing and i simply cannot oversee
everything
i've taken the liberty of transferring a
settlement to your account
to compensate for the damage done
special treatment
would you mind if we spoke elsewhere
i can't right now sorry
of course should you change your mind
don't hesitate to return
oh
what's up
hang on gotta go
[Music]
okay you were saying heard your home
already sure got that ear to the ground
anyway
you need something you know where to
find me
foreign
mr v hey i've been authorized to propose
an exclusive offer
are you interested in a business
arrangement with the delivery network
sure let me hear what you got lined up
splendid
i stand authorized to dispatch a drone
who will provide you with additional
details
v i truly hope you can excuse my sub
routine
completely absorbed hey i'm fully
perhaps a guided tour will prove some
form of compensation
this corridor links the shop to the
office
and here is where the magic happens the
shop is fully automated
alas the shop is currently overwhelmed
with work
i think i know why i'm still looking
into the cause of the delime network
vehicle fingers my working hypothesis is
an advanced virus
i must resolve the situation quickly but
this sudden rise in incidence is
the control room i feel honored to have
you here
rather surprisingly
all these lights what are they for
that's what i wish to discuss with you a
green light denotes a vehicle with which
i am in contact
as you can see that is no longer the
case for some vehicles
those are the red lights repair drones
can't take care of this
this time i fear human intervention is
required
i'm aware you offer a broad range of
services and are unusually discreet
thus i'd like you to assist me in
recovering my missing vehicles
okay sure i'll go after you missing
wheels
i'm pleased to hear it i shall send you
the coordinates of their last known
locations
you must simply deactivate each i'll
then re-establish the link
and return them to my garage see what i
can do
della main vehicles are exceptionally
secure be sure to have a scanner with
decryption capability on your person
so
so
hey
sure let me hear what you got lined up
[Music]
uh
i'd asked
you've accounted for all my lost items
allow me to express my gratitude for
your assistance
i felt like a scavenger hunt for a range
of your mood swings
more complex than i thought yes
well i've sent the final installment of
your theme
truly i thank you once again
thanks pleasure to work with you
likewise
i look forward to doing so again in the
future a pleasant day to you